and uh that takes us to the final match
of the day
which is uh the other match-up
i should say in uh in group b which is
uh between david pakman
easy with aces we've been hyping this
for a while my friends because we
haven't had a match to focus on and i
feel like it's finally here it's like a
ufc main event wait what do you mean you
didn't have a match did you not just see
what i did to ludwig there
okay all right i thought we moved past
that one just kind of looking for a
funsies one match
threw away my queen it wasn't really a
match it was more just like an
exhibition
i think you're right evie that this is
an exciting match because it's one of
the few
in group stages that will actually
determine something
uh outside of seating one we'll move on
to winners one will move on to the
loser's bracket
and it does seem like david is a bit of
a favorite here
in terms of his rating but
i bet any any betters on this one i'll
take
we're not allowed to do that as
commentators ludwig what do you mean
it's not like i'm
i'm i'm swaying discord
i i actually think finton is is my pick
to win this match
uh just having watched him play uh his
previous matches
he just seems very confident and i think
that's
that's underrated uh especially
in newer players just having confidence
in your moves
being able to play faster even if you're
down uh
rather than you know second guessing
everything like we saw dog dog do when
he lost to
zextra well i think they're both
very close even if somebody is a slight
favorite
and we just have takeoff so are we
do we have their game pulled up yep we
do uh we have a kara khan
and this is what easy with aces plays
it's the the true and tried the old
reliable
he played this against uh
hafu and okay david takes
which is this is already pretty good for
black
it's actually a pretty decent position
and
i think david went into a french
exchange in one of his previous matchups
as well
just trying to avoid some of the heavier
theory
yeah not not my weapon of choice
uh but that's the that's the beauty of
getting
coaching from multiple sources is that
you just can play simple chess
i will say just happened to open up
vincent's stream and he immediately said
i don't know this line of cairo khan
which is bad because it's move three
yeah that that is bad
again i see i was going to say
when you said vincent is like confident
maybe
maybe on on the inside because when he's
when he talks about his
chest he's very very kind of like humble
and reserved he's like i don't know this
but
this isn't groundbreaking stuff all
white did was trade pawns in the center
it can't be that good
so i just remember yeah sorry he just he
just went into uh
sorry one time he was playing he went
into a
studio office with like a a long chair
and a fireplace
which seems like a confident thing to do
for a chess player
he does it when he plays poker two i
think he does it to kind of regroup
mentally
uh and yeah he's very he could get the
hands waving i mean pacman just looks
like he's got a call out of jail maybe
like that's his one
phone call for the day this is like
obama looking at seal team six
he's just like he's just studying the
footage
he is locked in
that is my mind is one focused man
well i mean they have a very similar
amount of focus but i see that
david isn't actually streaming this
while finton is so fenton has a bit
more of a distraction yeah that is true
david didn't i don't think david didn't
stream
because of focus i think it's he might
be
he has two locations and sometimes he
goes to to like his second
place and his connection there is not
stable and he didn't want to connect to
a stream and to zoom so he chose one
over the other but uh he's he's got a
very very chill position here this is
they're both looking mighty fine
but what's next so finton just played
his bishop to d6 he's offering
up the trade i wonder if david is just
going to go for it i feel like that's
always the
most straightforward plan that we've
seen in pakistan so far just going for
the trade
simplified knight p5 i'm showing on the
board attacks the queen but it's not the
best move cause
easy with aces will move his queen that
ain't gonna fly here
you don't want to be a one-trick pony
right quite literally yes
but so that queen will go anywhere safe
at what level do people stop trading
because i feel like everybody loves
trading
at pogchamps level and then every
commentator is always
you know looking disdainfully at it
like early trades early trades i feel
like are a staple of low level play
i was gonna let alexandra take it away
well i mean you can do trades at any
level
i think it's when it seems like it's the
only option that is considered sometimes
at pogchamps level so i don't know if he
was thinking about
making moving his queen up to d2 to
defend his bishop instead and then
recapturing and activating the piece so
what i usually
realize is that players will go for
trades even if it's a sub-optimal move
and i almost never see them defending
the trade with a
subtle move like that yeah because you
have to
start at is it a fair trade if yes okay
play it that's always how you should
start as a vegan just if yes okay by all
means go ahead if you're making fair
trades but then it's like
at some point you go what has changed in
the position and you're you know
for a beginner the queen has gotten more
active for my opponent
isn't natural yeah because it's fair to
me as
i took horizon cores seems fair
uh but i don't consider that he will
take it with a piece that's now
activated
uh and pushed out into the board which
is reasonable because you don't want to
have
information overload when you're just
starting off with chess because it's
already
so overwhelming
so i think as coaches were happy to see
it i mean you coached both of them levy
how are you feeling about their play so
far
so this is great i have zero concerns
with them as far as the opening goes
because they're not prep monsters
whereas
like somebody like hafu she's gonna play
this very logically she's
gonna go the guy goes for this opening
the best way to play against it is to
surprise him with something i've never
done before
and play the most challenging weapon
and these guys are just like i want to
get a chess game
and then we'll figure it out so it's not
even like cheesing it or something like
that where you try to win in five moves
you're just trying to
maximize your winning chances and
putting pressure on your opponent but
finton has done everything you're
supposed to do in a karo khan
now let's see what comes next because uh
david will
you know is david gonna take or is david
going to play f2 f4 and guard his
central knight
right so this is one of the first
opportunities where we can see david
making a mistake
if he leaves his knight hanging on e5
and ends up losing a pawn but he goes
for knight b5 so he's attacking the
queen
yep and it looks like queen b6 looks
really good
what were you gonna say levy that's the
yeah queen b6 or
queen e7 actually any queen move which
is safe and on a dark square
is is totally fine uh if you go queen a6
you will run into the fork on c7 and he
plays queen v6 like it's good when
you're playing our moves
even ludwig's he's he's on fire today he
beat alexandra
so actually finton beat me in an odds
match before also
with what time idiom i think i may have
had like
15 or 20 i don't remember wasn't this
foray into chess not beating you when
you only had a king
yes and he had all his pieces how does
that even work multiple times
that was before chess was much of
anything at all and we had a few poker
people playing and and one day there was
an easy with aces alexandra botez
crossover and uh
now he's a thousand i didn't teach him
about stalemate yet so really i was just
choosing him i mean hey when's the win
or draws a draw i guess but he couldn't
win
but he's come really far since then
obviously
um you know he plays poker and he's used
to grinding out different games and he
was super busy
and now he's finally had a little bit
more time to focus on chess and look at
the improvement this is just
a fantastic play so far yeah very solid
position
a lot of games like this get decided
with uh
a combination of your piece play and
your pawn play so
uh okay so that move is an example of
peace play
but he's not realizing that just moving
the queen up one square there is a
lingering threat in the position that
alexandra wanted to uncork
with the queen where it stands
a6
ludwig if you're playing this position
with the black pieces what kind of plans
would you try to go for here
i'm looking at the board from black's
position uh i mean i think it's
for me it's just uh about getting rooks
in earlier
i feel like people just leave them
hanging like often
and then you enter end game and your
rook's still on a1 or something
and you read his mind there you go i
think that
is that and i know sometimes it really
doesn't matter is that the wrong
rook yeah yeah i think so but it's
in this case yes it still works but
usually right you want to take it like
left half rook takes left side yeah
because then your other rook has more
options for where he can go so in terms
of the piece play uh
david's pieces are see again like this
is moving far past the beginner's term
like they're they're standing pretty
confidently but they're poorly
coordinated
and and that's why because the knight is
blocking the queen from seeing the b2
pawn so you need to scan what's
unguarded in your position
and that's really the issue is that now
when the knight comes back if
if finton takes now it looks like his
queen is getting trapped
i don't know if he will i feel like he
did this to stack his
rooks and the only way to stack your
rooks is to get rid of that knight so
you can move your rook to c7
so i think that's what he's thinking is
go c7 bring the rook back stack them
rather than take but maybe now that the
knights kind of like
in this area and blocking the c file
even more or cluttering it up maybe
he'll see it
uh okay let's let's see what he's seeing
let's go to his stream
and then to like attack this but like i
don't i'm not sure
if we go
yeah so that was a guttural noise gonna
go back here i think
oh he just doesn't see it at all yeah
that was just totally different
he was doing a lot on the right and he
just said okay he's concerned about the
pawn
yeah he wasn't under threat though i
just i guess he's just very
it's a solid move though he's regrouping
his knight so
maybe not the most accurate but it's
like one of the top five moves he could
have done there
he sees the queen attack okay
he's deliberating what's the right
knight square here all right so we gotta
be careful because we gotta go here and
then if he attacks the square we gotta
be careful of the pin
or not to pin the fork we're just gonna
go here for a sec and start trying to
potentially counter
attack ourselves that's
correct yep yeah i would imagine that if
he brings this over here
we just want to move one of these
slightly so that he can't get this
square
and attack the two of them
see look at that very nice tactical like
he sees that that's possible if his
queen's not there so in the absence of
his queen
is to cover that threat like this is
yeah this is
two guys who are good at chess and he's
looking at like level two threats
don't hide pieces just don't hang pieces
let him hang pieces when he gets low on
time
exactly fits in take a swig take a swig
no obviously not oh and the live board
has a bad move
i think finton immediately recognized it
yes i apologize i thought i thought we
were so that's why i'm looking at this
other screen i'm still watching oh
you're good you're good yeah
um so this is
ah it's it's a mistake for like the most
subtle of reasons really it's a
positional mistake
right like what does that mean so
alexandra what
why is this not good why'd the eval bar
go well guys finten finton just
showed us why so he can now put his
knight on e4 and that's called an
outpost where no pawn can ever kick the
knight out of
because he put his pawn on f4 he created
some light square weaknesses so you
often think of
over expanding your pawns the square of
the color they
move to so f4 being dark then creates
weaknesses on the opposite color the
light square on e4
and this move is totally busted because
again
the positioning of the knight on the
edge of the board i think
that why it's it's so busted is is there
is b5 and not to mention the fact that
everything alexandria just said
uh queen takes pawn so that's really the
thing he had to maintain defense
of his f4 pawn and it's not defended
it's just a free pawn so the two things
the weak pawn and the bad knight and
well ludwig do you think he's gonna see
taking the pawn on f4 based on his play
so far
yeah i think absolutely i think i think
he'll notice that it's
that it's hanging because noticing the
night move i think is harder
that now you can push your knight and
it's
interesting because i feel like this
game was going really well
and then it felt like pac-man didn't
know what to do anymore you know felt
like he needed to make a move and you
keep having to advance
and you never just get to not do
anything uh and then you kind of
let finton's moves be easier because
so i actually i want to take it all the
way back to his third move
like the way he played and by the way
well okay he's going for the he's going
for the knight though yes
he did notice that he has this plan so
but finton for finton it was a
continuity problem
he forgot that the pawn i'm assuming we
weren't listening to him but
he forgot his queen had vision on the
pawn and the other queen
left that pawn b um yeah i actually saw
him arrowing his knight to f6
and e4 before he even made the move so
it seems like
it was always his plan to get the knight
in the center
so he just focused on that plan without
necessarily completing the tactic at the
end
yeah again this is only showing so
drastically in in
in finton's favor despite the complete
equality on the position
because of a move like b5 and wow he's
done it and now the knight has to go
all the way back to b2
good move and now his knight is dominant
over the center so
uh the reason it got so it it all ties
back to move three
is because david just basically traded
in the center and put his pieces out
but every opening is optimized
differently and he didn't set up the
like the right way to put pressure on
finton so now it's finton's game to play
for win
we know what's crazy it's minus four
according to the screen
and they're equal material that is
that's weird yeah
that's annoying that it's all back to
move three you know yeah
you did one thing wrong you're punished
so hard for it it's it's experience so
finton is like very
well versed in this opening but he's
missing one move you know small things
um and david's improvising like david
could have
shown up been like all right i'm gonna
play this variation this is how i'm
gonna put pressure on him
but not everybody wants to do that not
everybody wants to sit down and like try
to prepare 15
you know moves in a row and that's i
will say although that
advantage seems drastic on the
computer's reading i don't know if a
player
like of these caliber can really
capitalize well on it
no you have to take the free material
yeah yeah so if you don't get the free
material then the position no longer
matters yep uh when you don't know what
to do with it
and on top of that finton's time gap is
getting smaller now he used to be up
like a minute on the clock
yeah so the reason that this is so bad i
think is because here black can play
queen b6
and queen b6 attacks the central pawn
and you cannot protect it
like you cannot move your queen and if
you move your pawn
uh then i'm pretty sure is there knight
takes c3 here
oh that's a really cute tactic
right and then if rook c3 you have queen
d4 check
and you fork the rook with your queen
and the rook so like
but seeing that is ridiculous like if
that's the only line for advantage
how are you gonna find that yeah ludwig
what kind of
ideas would you go for from finton's
point of view here
oh not that one not that one oh
raisin why did he think that that knight
could do that
we talked about it equal material trades
go for it right
that night was so good the relative
value of that knight was way more than
that bishop that bishop hasn't moved
it's been 23 moves it moved once
now it's gone i think it's i i think
it's easiest just to take hanging pieces
and you get hanging pieces when you have
way more pieces that are active that can
threaten things
uh and your opponent has still you know
is rook on a1 and this is still playing
very well i don't want to cut you off
just
no nothing you're not i'm just saying
you know in general finton
rather than just having to continually
move the knight which is already doing a
lot
he can just bring out someone else into
the party and then hopefully have an
advantage
and at least he has the plan of doubling
his rooks on that c file so he's still
gonna put pressure
on c2 and that pawn is a little bit
awkward to move
because if he pushes to c3 then he won't
be protected by the queen anymore just
by the pawn
and c4 is going to be quadruple
protected by two pawns and two rooks so
at least he has
a target to keep pushing right and if
you you
trade c4 the improper way then the queen
now has vision on these central pawns
um but the way the way the game is going
it really just looks like david is is
unsure what to do he's trying to like
defend
everything and chess is just like this
if you have three weaknesses four
potentially
you can't defend them all you just can't
like there is a way through
but vinton has to find it
well pac-man has been playing his
defense very well he did
see how to maneuver his horse all the
way back to protect the pawn on f4 now
his knight is in the center
um i'm just getting a little bit nervous
uh two minutes versus three minutes how
much
of a difference do you think that'll
make ludwig that's huge right
uh like when obviously a minute time
difference
uh it's it's it's gonna stay that way
likely just they're probably gonna keep
playing the way they play
that's something i think about a lot is
like the way they play early game
is likely how they'll play late game or
it's how they're comfortable playing so
best kiss or worst case scenario
they'll just play worse uh and so i i
think
the way they're playing i don't think
pac-man has any really attack strategies
thought about
and fintense hasn't been working i'm
kind of nervous i think this will go
down to time
i really am am hesitant about this move
that david just played that rook on a2
not c1 i mean they're both a little bit
sus
they're not happy wow why do you look at
the other side of the board
i i think he's just getting nervous
because his pieces are so cramped on the
left side that he feels like he needs to
get some activity somewhere
and then he's doing something that he
knows is a little bit
suspicious you don't want to push the
pawns in front of your king but you also
don't want to lose on time
how do you pick i feel like where this
is this is where it all implodes
like they're very even game in terms of
points he's about to oh
i mean that's a fine move for finton
it's a little bit passive
but his opponent is the one with all of
the weaknesses yet his opponent is the
one pushing forward here
and fenton sees the discovery attack
on the rook on c1 the fact that the pawn
on c2 is pinned very nice find on his
end
yeah that actually is very nice
sometimes when you have
two rooks like this it's not just about
the straight down attack it's about
sliding over one square and the rook on
the on the back rank is
just stuck but oh this is good i
like this a lot f6
he is creating counter play there
even if it's not accurate at least it
makes spinton sweat a little bit would
you be intimidated to see a pawn on f6
ludwig yeah i mean this is like they're
both just attacking and no one's
defending it feels like
he just caged he just caged this bishop
but he can uncage him with g5 later not
if not if david pakman plays the
absolutely gangster move g5 himself
i don't think that's even a thought that
will cross his mind
oh my i mean yeah i don't think so i
think what's much more natural is to
play queen h4 queen takes pawn and queen
queen g7 mate which might happen
wow his plan is actually kind of working
out depends on the execution but
pacman's only gonna have a minute to
come up with a plan and
i feel like he's gonna sink so much of
his time on
a winning strategy here so if he finds
it he has a chance otherwise
he's going for it uh that move might run
into g5 by the way for black
i think pretty clearly right it feels
supernatural for anyone to put g5 up
n not well he like he might do it but
finton might be the kind of guy that's
like i don't want to push pawns in front
of my king i'm going to
drop my queen all the way back but that
would be
a big mistake or he pushes on the right
this feels like the
chess version of slapboxing where
they're what is that
you ever see like the the russian where
they just slap each other as hard as
they can
oh yeah that's like what's happening
they just keep slapping yeah
[Music]
they're ignoring everything they're just
slapping each other and then they get
hit and they never
ever ever think about blocking they just
go for this blocking david actually no
you're right he's slapping no
they're just slapping no one's ever
defending what's happening on the other
side of the board
the issue with this is that finton has
to defend the g7
square with his queen but then if
pac-man trades off queens
there's gonna be no more protector for
his work on a3 and you can
tell from finton's face that he realizes
something went down
and then we're listening in on him
damn glass is off i don't think that's
wow okay maybe time-wise he won't close
it out but this is
not good
oh man he uh okay we gotta display crick
right
okay yeah let's just let's let's let's
bring it back to the big board
i mean you know it's like it's like in
the ufc when they don't
you don't get an interview if you just
get knocked out like
injured player yeah like i mean look at
them in pain
yeah um
yeah like but pretty sick attack from
from from pac-man
yeah wow f6 was really good it actually
was really good yes
and i really think it was just neither
player ever looking to defend the attack
that was happening to them at any point
right and at some point you just want to
halt all the threats before you carry on
with your plan
still i mean clinton has an extra minute
here
and he has one pass pawn so there's
still a chance
oh no a4 has to be played yeah
okay rook ba oh now david just goes rook
a8 he could just clean this up actually
rook b5
even you can okay style points
okay see knight a6 not you got you gotta
trade
you gotta trade and
the story of the sad bishop on h7 this
was a good game i mean whatever happens
it was actually like just a
it was a good fight and credit to
pac-man for bringing it back
i don't know if it's over yet with the
time constraint
he's gonna have to move fast and i don't
think sacking a rook
is natural ooh b3
that's a nice find c takes g3 doesn't
work because the rook on c1 is hanging
and he's back 30 seconds
it's getting to pac-man oh my goodness
he eddie's played g5
if pac-man had ever played g5 his bishop
would have just been stuck
he just unfreed the beast got back
material
damn this is uh oh my god
this is a swingy game oh you called it
you said it wasn't over
well yeah i mean 30 seconds left levy's
talking about these
mating patterns like they're so obvious
like just
you were offering a trade of rook it
looked like the dumbest move a man could
make
i'm just thinking i mean you have 36
seconds to make the best move possible
uh yeah it's uh well let's put it this
way
after that lesson with uh well actually
after that game with hafu
um i thought that mr pakman got
a few end game training sessions in but
you're right at the end of the day it's
just the time and this is only losing
because he's supposed to go after the
weakness of the f7 pawn
but finton's back in this game he's
actually
forcing finton to activate his king
which is something he wants to do
regardless so he's helping his opponent
without realizing it
yeah i think that's a very common thing
to have happen is that you don't
activate your king unless someone
threatens it and it's usually
bad for you to do that unless there's a
way to you know
force the king into a mate right he's
going for that serotonin check
it feels good it has a threat he moves
quickly oh man
you could really mess up here oh man
this is this is really dangerous i mean
the time management now check and pick
up the pawn
is the easiest or great move yeah now
you've got to move the rook all the way
back
12 seconds though you guys think we're
gonna see a flag here
i mean he should know about the time i
just
i think eventually he'll get hit with a
move that he won't be able to mentally
deal with quick enough
whether it's a check on his king right
or something like that
that'll just eat up too much time he's
taking like
more than five seconds per move right
now oh no
is this going to be the move okay he got
it in there and finished him
ah this might be it hinton's actually
playing extremely well with the time
is he gonna see the pawn on b3 also
right and there's also rook d3 check you
can start picking up everything
david pakman has to have a moment here
where he uh
he goes either for the f7 pawn or some
fork with the knight like don't give up
someone in my chat said i said
you can never give up as long as the
knight is on the board
and i said that's stupid and then i won
with a night fork in a
in a crazy time scramble i've never
remembered that one viewer did you vip
him at least levy
i uh you know tier three sub um
and and and the whole deal yeah i'm
never resigning he's got two seconds
yeah wow brooke is hanging is he going
to see the rook hanging he's going to
move the rug
wait oh did he ponder the rook is that
official
yeah he did he did he blunted the rook
oh no it's good for him because now he
won't even be in check with the bishop
well now if the rook checks him he's
taking away the defender from the king
but he can attack the rook
so that his bishop is actually surviving
i think the best thing he could do
is just keep putting fenton in check
because
one it'll make fenton have to think
about his move and two will just give
him time
this is so hard to win because you have
to get the g5 pawn or the f7 pawn the
only way to win
no he missed it he missed it fitting
missed it immediately
the bar is going out and walks away in
your chairs
all right i have loads of time every i i
don't need to be panicking like this
why am i just not taking my time i'm
taking these pieces and not
laundering we were doing lovely it was
perfect
oh no
oh he's back in it let's put it let's
pull it up let's pull it up let's pull
it up that was actually a huge move
that was a big lesson there um finton
centered himself
right at the critical moment i'm not
sure you guys if you guys saw like the
threat was to take the bishop and that's
it he's winning again this is this is
his game to win
but it's still a very tough end game to
understand
don't push the pawn do not push the pawn
and lose your bishop good man bishop g6
it's it's it's difficult but not
impossible because you just push your
pawns right like that's
i think pushing pawns is incredibly
strange
and you end up like you gotta you got no
way to win this
sometimes just getting boned and it
feels like you shouldn't have gotten
boned that's a very
that is a good way of looking at it
thank you
well he's activating his king which is a
good attempt but it's not going to be
able to come
further because f5 is protected by the
pawn no draw
i think pac-man would love a draw here i
think pacman would be super happy if you
could find a draw here
and and easy with aces just says no
thanks
no thanks
again i think these checks are just to
get five seconds on the board real quick
oh and here comes the king oh
he's throwing his pawn he's giving his
pawn away on f6 i don't know the fact oh
he does see it
oh my goodness he got fined i should
pass the move
i mean when his brain is only thinking
about check to add time to see that pawn
i think it's pretty hype
this is an insane game this is a 76 move
game right now
we might get a hundred wow
well we weren't kidding when we said
this is going to be one of the closest
matches today
now finton has to find the right
coordination of moving his bishop and
pushing this pawn yes it's equal but
it's equal because black
actually in theory cannot make any
progress because if you do like the
bishop here i play rook
up and i take your pawn so the bishop
has to stop that from happening
and the players don't know that which is
why this is so beautiful
yeah this is definitely not a draw the
computer's wrong i'll say it computers
are dumb and when they become
advanced and they come after me i will
regret saying that
it was me it was lovely it was lovey i
saw that i i think i think something
will
will erupt here and yeah
yeah go ahead i was gonna say there's no
way he can defend his pawn on g5 so the
only counter play he can get oh this is
crazy
oh my gosh the two pawns are about to
happen he's got to be really damn
careful because if this g-pawn goes it
is faster
than oh man i don't like bishop e4 what
happens when i just push
right you're not stopping the pawn and
you're blocking your own pawns
from pushing forward here now oh
no g6 is still
a true no i think it should be this
should be lost
weird to not push g6 i feel like that
was pretty oh oh
now he can play rookie king age five and
now this pawn can't move forward so it
should should be able to hold now
strange decision
why did you find it strange well i just
you're obviously like pushing the pawn i
don't know what that rook move did at
all wow
so clean blocking the rook from
defending the pawn on g5
wow that's actually brilliant and now if
if paquin plays something like rookie
eight you know trying to get his own
another pawn for himself
what so that's it he lost the pawn it
that's it that king moved well there was
nothing he could have done he can't
defend his pawn
well he could have attacked the other
pawn though then he would have lost the
rook
that's what i was saying that bishop
takes rook yeah yeah uh this is oh
that's not the right move because of
that that is
you get blockaded you have to avoid this
and this is
somewhere cringing
does the eternal pog champ oh that's it
shuffle draw
get out of here drop oh yeah i think
they're both happy to take it at this
point
91 move draw wow wow i remember
somebody said we aren't going to see any
draws in pogchamps here it is
yeah that that gets a clap from us that
was a good game
that was and now we have a second game
coming up in like two minutes we don't
even take a break let's keep on rolling
yeah that was like i think both sides
had pretty clear advantages
and possibilities to win i both
threw it away it seems like a fair
result
yeah that's that's honestly just the way
you put it like
uh chess when it's not with super gms
or frankly like master level players
or computers you don't know that it's so
drastically in the favor of one side or
the other it's like a sporting event you
know
plus seven minus seven it's just points
put the ball in the hoop
in the goal just keep playing love you
watches sports
i do i do put the hoop in the ball there
you go
that's not what i said i'm messing with
you i think
i'm surprised i want to draw i'll be
honest i think they played it
incredibly well with time crunch and uh
and like a weird weird end game that i'm
sure
neither of them have really played
before oh that
that's yeah this is one of the best
played games i've seen
so far in pog jam and we're off to the
next one so now finton has the white
pieces
and they don't even get a break to to
calm down from the nerves they're
probably a little bit shaky
yeah uh for for the fact that
hafu had to sit and wait for xuc to wake
up for like 20 minutes before getting an
official default like we could have
given them like an extra two minutes
come on guys
these guys just back into it sweat it
out man look they need to be in the
mindset
okay i think this is going to be a
king's indian defense from david pakman
so i will help him with this opening at
all
i no no actually
like not helped for this match but okay
couple okay that's just a
losing mistake wait what because knight
e4
yeah 94 just wins on the what i wouldn't
say win on the spot he's gonna end up
winning a pawn which
you know it's not the end of yes
the game oh my goodness and david has
spotted it he's not even pre-moving he's
just
ah wow
why is that so good
to see one yeah and then then
take take and then take on d4 okay
you're up a pawn you're threatening this
oh my goodness wow
what a mistake it's a very good start
for pac-man but again
i know that you know levy you do
commentary on hikaru magnus and
this would be completely winning if
either side had it
but i i'm not gonna call it yet
i think that these guys are at that
level or close to it
are you confident he sees bishop oh yeah
he didn't even see it and alexandra
just proved a point and david did not
see bishop takes pawn
low players too much credit man i i like
i
saw the thing i saw the fork and i was
like oh hell yeah
and then i saw the defense on the fork
and i was like ah damn it and that's
where my thoughts
ended um and i'm sure pac-man was with
me on that one i'm angry i gotta i gotta
record a
happy one million youtube subscriber
celebration
for david yeah yeah for david and i'm
gonna put that i'm gonna be like david
you'd be fast you don't know how bishops
move anymore man like on the biggest
stage you forget that
happy million but this piece moves
diagonally buddy yeah you you you
oh i can't even okay game goes on i mean
i just
i'm just cheering for good chess and i'm
cheering for chat energy and we've had
high energy for like two hours now so
but why what is the pacman
joke uh like just park champ
background oh i'm assuming cause you're
doing a package
uh well no because it's pac-man so pag
pack
pack and they're doing pag chomp pac-man
got it okay there we go catching up on
the twitch lingo you think i'd get it
right now
we're getting there listen all of all of
twitch chess as
as much as we work to fit in it's only
been about three and a half months
since we learned about every emote right
like we're getting on our feet but
take it easy on us well
david definitely took it easy on easy
with aces here
that was not my smoothest transition but
i tried you do
all right um so the pawn on f6
it's a very awkward position to have a
pawn
how intuitive do you think it is for him
to push it twice ludwig would you go for
a move like f5 here
i think it's it's like it's a it's a
it's a backdoor trick
so like that bishop actually sees a lot
but it's blocked by your own pawn
so you save it until you can find a
really good threat so maybe
like right now he pushes up his pawn and
then you know
uh bit maybe baiting white into taking
that pawn
if you do that then you push it and then
you're threatening the pawn
on b2 which threatens the rook
yes i like it so it's like
you're like you're basically saving your
your
your little back door very sneaky
yeah yeah that's what i would do with it
i feel like pac-man and i are in similar
wavelengths
and i think i think he sees that so he
probably won't push it unless he sees a
clear threat that he can do with it
i think that's maybe why he's trying to
remove
the piece on d4 and finton decides to
leave the pawn on d4 which is actually
one of the
more difficult decisions to make
whenever you have a trade you're tempted
to take it or to push it
but he continues developing which i like
he's
going with a very straightforward castle
your king as quickly as possible plan
which is
very different than we saw in our first
game today
i think centered pawns it's the one
piece where you're like ugh i guess i
won't throw it away because my coach
will yell at me
do you actively think about coach or the
best move on the board
every opening i thought about hikaru for
minutes on
end while i did the room the exact
things he told me not to do
oh you ever have nightmares of ikaro
yelling at you yeah just his face
grimacing and like oh that thing yeah
that's all i'm thinking about when i'm
[ __ ] up my uh opening
oh no yeah let's see that's why i told
my parents early on no coaches and
they're like but you're never going to
fulfill your potential i was like
no coaches see that's and they were and
they were wrong
you're doing it big and great there you
go
oh i was going to say they totally were
right i didn't become a grandmaster so
you know well bishop e4
so he's moving his bishop twice and he's
putting pressure on b7 which
it's a nice threat but it's very easy to
stop
and it was stopped now don't take the
knight because then
just get a nice bishop okay
again it's minus two but like it's equal
why is it minus two
you know what levy let's just ignore
that computer for now it does not matter
the computer is wrong this is the one
place where ludwig chest if you guys
heard the game of ludwig chess
um no what is ludwig chess it's where
you play chess but the computer analysis
is next to the board at all times and
you can see it
interesting but you can't play i guess
you're just doing practice games
yeah but like both yeah both players
would see it so you'd be playing better
i think it would throw people oh
both players would yeah both players
both players see it oh i thought you
just admitted to cheating okay
both players get to see the gases
uh both players get to see it i think it
would mess with people's minds to
see minus two and you think you have a
sick tactic right it's just
dumb position stuff yeah so you're not
even you're saying just the eval bar
going forward
guys he's going for it yep he is he does
see it the back of the bishop the bishop
yeah the bishop
you've been dreaming about trust trust
it's what pac-man has dreamed of it's
what i've dreamed of
oh man and finton cannot defend both the
knight and the b-2 pawn so he might as
well
go for something tricky yep yep pac-man
won't miss it
oh that was a big mistake because now
when he moves what did i tell you guys
you're right lightweight you found the
back door it's beautiful this is
beautiful
i love the way pacquiao is playing we
should right
yeah and add it to your old you know pog
champ score and take that win away from
charlie
is the bad thing here especially that he
moved his knight to block the rook so
now he can't even take the bishop
yes you nailed it yeah so it's not only
like
he messed up on letting that happen in
the first place he messed up defending
it too
yeah his his one hope now is to play
knight c3
block out this bishop completely and
just do what david did last game
just shred open the position with the
pawns because the position's so closed
you can't do anything
so you have to play moves like f3 maybe
g4
otherwise are you gonna create counter
any sort of counter play
yeah i don't is is this this is fenton
thinking right now
yeah yeah he's in a really losing spot
and i there's no
amazing trick he can do i don't know if
he's trying to look for one
yeah well he's i mean also just
recovering from missing that he missed
it he missed bishop takes pawn
yeah i mean the only thing he can try to
go for here is take advantage of the
fact that david still has his king in
the center of the board
and try to open the position up as
quickly as possible
before he castles so something like f3
it's not winning but at least it gives
him some chances
let's hear what he thinks about i'm
curious
interesting
and he goes for that plan that's that's
nice to see
yep f3 played
now he has to just follow up
[Music]
i like his title pog champs match to be
in the winner's bracket or the all caps
losers bracket because like an emphasis
was put on purpose
yes a little bit so mad i didn't convert
the last game
oh wow still holding on to that that's
tough
that's chess man that's just deflating
it's very deflating to have to think
about how you could have won a previous
game while you're still playing a game
but don't you feel like you do that with
any game not just chess when you have
multiple rounds
hell no only chess for me
only chess i don't know about ludwig i i
think i mean it's just bad mentality so
i try to move on from it you know what i
mean
okay okay that's like i think it's bad
and i hate especially in team things
where people are talking about the last
round
of whether it's ballerina there's
another round that we're playing
right now it's just a waste oh okay well
as far as that goes yeah that does i
mean it's i play overwatch
it's it's always someone else's fault
i've never ever been in a lobby where
someone went yeah my bad
you know that was me
only when you played with friends they
were like yeah i wasn't healing enough
what
i thought you were supposed to what okay
i don't even know who i'm supposed to be
mad at now
so wholesome yeah no chess is brutal
um and it can affect you game to game
at least he you know took on d4 now
um david is gonna have to find some way
to get his king into safety because he's
up
a full rook but while the position is
closed
you're not really playing with those two
rooks yet right
exactly and if he doesn't castle like he
brought his bishop back
just now and his logic was probably i
don't want my bishop to get stuck
but what i always challenge him easy
with ace is like any of these guys
it's like okay don't just say my bishop
is gonna get trapped
how what's the move and if there isn't a
move it's not gonna get trapped his only
issue is he needs to castle and if he
doesn't do that
clinton has a chance because like
alexandra said if you don't castle how
are these rooks ever getting activated
don't know what he's going to play here
he should castle by the way probably
it's probably the best move
i think he's set up oh he did it yeah
nice job
i think he set up really well because
last game i mean i think part of the
reason why i went to a draw is because
he was down a minute
and time is really even this game
it is yeah well then going back to
finton's position here
levy if you're trying to be as tricky as
possible now your opponent castled
how are you gonna try to achieve them um
yeah so i
don't know because my
my first instinct was to take this
bishop and then try to push
right but like okay i move you just
you just can't get in i mean you check
the guy with your queen the queen
can take a pawn maybe but probably this
though probably if i have to choose
something get the queen
into the center try to go wooden shield
not quite but it's difficult you
there you can also run into the problem
in this kind of a position where if you
trade too much
you activate your opponent's pieces all
of a sudden
right because so another strategy could
just be trying to play it
safe something like knight f2 which is
incredibly difficult to see
um and you're just trying to hold down
the four protect your pieces and hope
that
david stays too long thinks on time
you get lucky in the end feels like the
opposite's happening and
fenton's thinking a little too long is
this a this is a minute move
a minute move and i'm guessing half of
his thought went probably just
to realizing the blunder and getting
over that from what we
found out listening in on his stream
yeah
well ludwig so you have this super
healthy gamer mentality did you always
have that or was there a pivotal moment
for you pretty much came out the woman
pro gamer
yeah it came out as a little controller
well but pro gamer and
you know healthy mindset aren't the same
so
actually actually true uh yeah i i i
just think uh
i mean it's just like i think i'm
generally optimistic which helps a lot
in
you know things where you have to deal
with like a loss
uh and so not beating yourself up yeah
like taxes
exactly i think though the only time i
ever beat myself up is when i can't do
anything about it anymore
because like if you can still do
something about it then why the [ __ ] are
you wasting your time
thinking about how you lost when you can
literally change the outcome
but if you lose lose then you can be sad
only then can you give yourself
the time to give yourself pity or regret
or whatever
but if there's still a chance to do
something why are you wallowing in
self-pity
wow did you just give chad a
motivational speech
i think it's true i think they're just
uh talking about chads and dormies right
now
chad is in a very very heated discussion
let's please not interrupt them
it's like whacking a beehive i'm afraid
i
don't know who's winning but one is yeah
i don't worry we we see on there's
there's also you know others i see i see
val kids in there all right anyway
um back to the the board david's
thinking
which is good but not for four more
minutes
yeah minute move into minute move they
have been very much great
rivals doing a lot of things similar and
it's
really been who makes the last blunder
um
or i guess in the last one just
repeating the position because they both
panicked a little bit
yeah i think pac-man recognized he had a
pretty big lead
probably the biggest of either uh either
of them
last game that was a draw so i'm sure he
doesn't want history to repeat itself
so he's going for queen takes h2 uh
that's a pretty annoying threat for
finton to deal with because if he pushes
one of the pawns then he'll create a
weakness
if he puts his rook on h3 it feels a
little bit like awkward positioning
okay h3 huh hey i got a prediction uh
you could play rook h3 here and
rather than going all the way back he's
gonna go well why don't i just like
centralize the queen somehow i mean i
know you can take on c4
but you could somehow get your queen
like
trapped in the center of the board in
some crazy turn of events
i'm just looking for some sort of sign
of life from fenton he can't spend a
minute on every move at some point he
does have to start
playing a little bit faster all right
well let's hope that he sees rook h3
just to make things more interesting
because that gives black the most tricks
he could potentially fall for
yeah g3 or h3 is like also playable
taking the bishop to just get rid of
that threat completely
you to play knight takes bishop like i
said you got five pieces left
and okay he does it nice job he doesn't
but now he's got four pieces left so
simple math at some point you will
unfortunately run out and
why is david thinking here
i think he just yeah he's very caught he
just does not want it to end up like
last game
okay and you have time right you have
time and you have a lead
true but if 10 moves from now you have
30 seconds then it's like
we didn't need to spend 20 seconds on
pawn takes right we just well it's also
like it's very it can be as simple as my
opponent took a minute
so let me take logger because maybe they
did something clever
interesting potentially you think that
your opponent's taking longer because
they're doing something smarter
when in reality they're usually just
[ __ ] well i usually think of my
opponent takes a minute that damn they
probably did something insane here
right or yeah in my case anytime i'm
playing hikaru and he's thinking and
then my chat relays to me that uh oh
wait something's happening on this board
right now that is a potentially
brilliant trap
but when i play hikaru they're saying oh
he's showing his computer parts or
doing a house tour and i'm like dude i
thought i made him think yeah you know
bobbing tava yeah um queen takes pawn
is losing now right you get bishop
b3 pinning the queen and the king
that do you think you set that up on
purpose oh my gosh
no way no way little you think he just
absolutely i don't i don't think
even if he takes the pawn i don't know
if fenton would see it
he could just be trying to do what i
said like set up the queen check and
see the problem with a move like d6 is
all of a sudden your opponent goes
oh i can move my bishop here you know i
never was able to do that before and i'm
attacking a rook
so i'm gonna play bishop c6 and you
accidentally help them but i will say
there's a lot of
options for black here and whenever you
have a lot of options you might start
thinking
too much on a ton of different moves
and he can't do that right now between
place queen g4
okay push the h-pawn bait him into
taking the pawn
because he moved yeah that's a good idea
once to the right so if you attack the
queen he's gonna keep looking to the
right
and take the pawn and run into bishop b3
imagine that's a good idea in theory i
think what would happen if he
pushes the h pawn is he's not pushing it
with the idea of
that you know what i mean he's just
pushing it to get the queen out of there
because the queen's stressful
yeah that also is true he also could
just give him a check with the queen
himself uh he's got two minutes based
off game one the check makes more sense
yeah because they remember
how they just kept attacking and never
defending yes
you got their playing style down ludwig
yeah
this is still kind of inconvenient
because if
you i told david pakman a long time ago
don't pin yourself when you get into
checks he would block a lot
right now if he plays rook in front of
king it's a good move it might be the
best move
because you're bringing your second rook
but that's the tricky thing you know
that
thing comes in like oh i shouldn't pin
myself but it's not general
it's just more often than not if you're
in an equal position
just move your king to the side but if
he does that now to the corner
finton plays queen takes pawn check it
would be hilarious to see him then put
his king back on g8 give another check
and get another repetition
i know it won't happen but that would be
such a fun armageddon
technical force i think he's probably
looking oh and he does it good that's
the right thing to do
at taking oh oh no i don't i don't like
that you don't want to get rid of your
pieces here
you don't have many left right i thought
he was gonna take the pawn on b7
to be honest yes he actually his queen
could have taken three pawns
yeah could have taken c5 e5 d7 uh oh but
if wait if pawn takes here
rook g3 wins the queen
right so he is setting up a trap again
we don't know
oh oh my goodness rook g3 he has to see
it it
has to be your comeback oh no he's
hovering over his knife
i don't think he sees it man he dropped
the knight he dropped the knight
oh and and david's realized that look at
david's face david is
yeah and he's played it it's on the
board oh
clutch gamer oh my god
holy smokes what seems like in shock oh
let's go to a stream
i nearly didn't see it because i'd lost
[ __ ] hope
oh no why was that there for have i
missed this for several moves no it's
just this move right
oh man i nearly missed it because my
head was up my [ __ ] arse mad at the
last game
yeah that's why you gotta bounce back
all right let's get let's get this on
the big screen i mean
he is he is locked in he is locked in
and alexandra you and i have played a
lot of competitive chess
uh that's exactly how it feels you were
playing
last round's game during your current
game you were just
wallowing in anger and sadness and
disgust
okay so i hear ludwig talking about this
positivity but
you know when you're used to giving your
your heart to a game it's so hard to get
over it
yeah gosh take everything the queen just
going to destroy everybody
also when you play a game like poker
where at the end of the day
you play right and you can blame rng
chess you just can't
right you always have to blame yourself
and you always have to take all the
[ __ ] you know the front of the load
well so one minute versus two minutes
that's actually a
huge time difference but playing against
two rooks is very tricky
yeah and a bishop yeah and a bishop i
guess that knight is an active joke yeah
that knight hasn't done anything
it it literally hasn't moved oh and he
hasn't seen it queen takes pawn there
was
was winning because he maintains defense
and now david has to find rook to e4
probably i would imagine or
yeah he's got a crazy coordination here
where
his rooks cover the king completely like
his king is totally safe
big big brain moves in the in the
chest.com chat saying move the knight
um they are not wrong you should do that
okay so much time david took
so much time when he was ahead and he's
now down i think he's up by a full
minute at one point
so now the rook should block king of
eight
might be possible with queen coming in
black's king is safe the rooks
and the bishop cover but how how long do
you think he should be spending on moves
like this levy
well look i don't blame the man i mean
he's going through everything
right now that finton was going through
the whole game
he was winning i mean he's just winning
and he blunders and now he's like damn
it i gotta pick myself up
guys it's the same time situation as
last game 140 versus 20
seconds so we'll see if finton learned
from his mistakes because yet last game
he kept playing quickly when david would
play quickly so maybe he'll realize he
has more time
i think he would absolutely
be so sad if he did it twice in a row
where he threw away a lead
yeah i don't think he could handle that
so i think i think he will try
everything in his power to play really
slow and smart
which might also end up screwing him
true there's
there's no perfect way he's is he
finally gonna get his knight into the
game because that rook is inviting
the horse into development
i don't know i don't love that he's
taking a minute on this
oh my gosh are we gonna get another
repetition
kg7 queen back
i don't think he blocks rookie six okay
yeah yeah he has to finten has to move
his knight he's just forgetting probably
not now hopefully
he takes care of his queen first
okay that's not a bad move at all i mean
you just again you gotta hump the pawns
down
you're only gonna win oh no oh no queen
c5 oh no wait
uh yeah queen c5 now the rook is hit and
you're threatening d7 and d8
this could be it david rookie one looks
really tempting here and he's done it
and he's gonna take the knight but
d7 and the queen gets through and it's
gonna be two queens but he has to see it
he has to
be bold to assume he'll see it oh he
does oh my god frame one
oh my goodness he's that's it he's gonna
get a second queen it's over
well it's not over yet we've learned
that yeah
that's insane though that was very quick
do not go king g1 because then rook g2
and then do not go king h1 and he's just
running into the middle of the board no
more checks
that's that's actually very hard to see
it's not intuitive to put your king in
the center of the board this quickly no
no it's not but he noticed that there
are no checks everything is covered and
david pakman
oh feels like he's resigned himself he's
slumped a bit
on finton again
he's not speaking of course he's so
focused at this point
going for the checks
he's just he's just trying to i mean
he's just trying to check every i mean
his heart must be pounding it's like
anytime i make it to the hexagon
only happened twice by the way serious
newbie over here all right
let's pull this up on the big screen how
do you put this away you're right
alexandra
i'm not sure this is over at all it's
two queens versus two rooks
i mean those are both some pretty heavy
pieces
oh my goodness and i mean you can't even
sacrifice that's the thing sometimes you
just you just give one away
but you can't because you're not winning
[Music]
okay it's still winning i i got scared
for a second i think i was trying to
figure out why you were freaked out
i i thought that there was a pin and i
hallucinated i'm just scaring chat
that's all i mean this is i think
paganism what he did last game where
he's just putting him in check to gain
some time on the board
he's very good at that oh my god pawn b6
and pawn a5
and the king is trapped i mean he can
sack his queen but
that would be huge progress oh no not
that this one this is insanity this is
this is the craziest matchup we might
have ever seen in pogchamps
and if he plays rook g6 then he has made
in one
maiden one is he gonna see it queen back
to h3 is checkmate and he's missed it
and he's given a queen away
oh oh why did you do that move
oh my gosh this is astounding this is
complete that was from maine
one to plus three oh no
oh no this might not e no th this is
this we might get a repetition
dude it's gonna go to a it's going to
armageddon dude
i don't think he's finding this oh my
god
i'm shocked i'm actually com i'm blown
away this is insanity
i mean at this point they can just
get rid of the nerves repeat the
position and give
give the audience that's what they did
last game right so it felt like they
both kind of threw away their
opportunity realized it and they're like
okay let me just stop this game
this game sucks let's go let's try again
they're doing it oh changed his mind he
says
i'm the one with the queen i'm gonna
push the pawn and he's doing the right
thing uh
david has to play bishop d7 which is a
ridiculous move to spot to win the pawn
that's what he has to do bishop d7
now it is winning again because the
pawns pushed and the queen can go
and it's easier to find checks when
you're the side playing with a queen so
finten should be a bit more comfortable
because if he panics he can just go for
a check
yes oh queen d6 and you win the bishop
just queen d6 oh just queen d6 is not
that easy to see
hey hey it's the closest check you said
it was easy to look for checks okay he
finds a long check because he's a
gangster and he wants to flex on
everybody but
he can move his queen to c7 after the
king moves up and win the bishop still
oh oh
queen takes pawn
i i actually this is crazy now david's
just going to play h5 davis is going to
run with his pawn right okay
check for time check for time the
classic david pac-man
check for time yeah he has to
but now the king is coming closer oh no
yep just king is coming closer now he
plays h5
oh i don't know he might play rook takes
pawn but you can't separate your rook
and king that much
oh
okay he's checking the king not as solid
e7 okay he's just picking up the pawn
there it is
there it is there's so many queen tricks
he is going for your plan he just
doesn't have much else here so he might
as well push that pawn
i think finton might be thinking about
stopping the pawn more than
doing an attack here because in his mind
if he gets rid of that paul
that's just all the pawns he wins so
bishop g6
is is not quite working but he has to
see why and that that why is king to f6
vintage time uh scary second
when he found it and the absolute madman
the king attacks both pieces
i don't have lots of time anymore
this is crazy pac-man getting into 10
seconds he didn't take the bishop
oh god oh god oh my
god oh but how does he how does he do
this to himself
how can i not close this out i have time
to be upset
oh how does he do this to himself man
i mean i feel like being a poker player
for for a living you're
you're used to so many ups and downs
you'll get through
the pain
all right let's let's let's let's pull
it back i
i just don't want to get caught in there
he is oh man
all right all right i guess we were back
already yeah now he's just got to push
this
he's just got to push this check from
pac-man calling it all
weird only way the only way pac-man wins
this game
is if you if you x-ray or skewer the
king to the queen that is the only way
you can win
queen takes rook in any circumstances at
least to draw like now
like don't play queen f4 queen h4 queen
h4 loses the game it's like the only
move that loses i think
okay it checks him even queenie too
uh trading off the queen of the pawn for
the rook and the bishop would still end
up winning but
it's not the most obvious endgame tactic
to see
but he might do it without knowing oh he
lost the game
you called it no you called it oh my god
do we do we know that pac-man knows how
to do a a rook
king mate oh resign why did he resign he
should have tried why would he resign
he shouldn't resign there's a chance
david wouldn't have done it oh
that is so so sad
finton oh my goodness my i
am i'm in physical pain after going down
so far
and then bringing it back and then
throwing it at the last second why would
he resign that's so sad
yeah but that's yeah let's uh
let's gather our energy let's take a
quick break i mean listen if
if we get both of them for an interview
that would be that would be super uh
we're definitely gonna speak with david
uh quick break
and we'll be right back welcome back
everybody oh are we
who's doing it take it let me take it
levy you're doing that at the same time
all right that was a
whatever um we're usually in sync it's
okay gentlemen thank you for two
absolutely amazing chess games i
i don't know what i don't know i don't
know where to go from here
um well david
we'll start you you won you're moving on
to the champions bracket
how do you feel just just how do you
feel how do you well i
i i feel very stupid because
much like in my first game against hafu
um i because of a mouse click error
i lost i lost the position so move
40 in game one okay i played
on captures on b3 my intention was to
play
c3 uh
pawn captures on b3 oh
oh oh oh the the move that changed the
game
yeah it was just a mouse click error i
uh oh my gosh
i'm frequently drawing arrows all the
time and it's hap now i need to stop
because
it's now happened twice that i'm trying
to draw an arrow
and i took and what i meant to do was
play c3 which in looking at the
evaluation would have kept me at plus
five
although i am getting double question
marks now when i analyze it so maybe it
was not the best move
but i did not mean to take the pawn so
you need one of those are you sure you
want to do this move buttons
yeah like last two minutes if it weren't
and i i would benefit from something
that outside of the last two minutes
it would oh wait that was outside of the
last two minutes anyway i don't know but
that was a mouse
error yeah i my question to finton was
going to be like
look they're they're truly as nothing
quite as painful as as as the ups and
downs
games in a row yeah i mean i i i
i first of all i've been there myself
and like um
this is a 40 minute 50 minute i mean you
guys played
the two most hardcore games i know we
might have ever seen in a pog champs but
uh do you take
anything positive out of it because you
you are
going to be in consolation but you
should be you know
like there should be a wild card do you
feel like the uh i don't think you got
any consolation out of losing but
it doesn't hurt that much i mean i'm not
going to get too hung up on it
david made less um london i did at the
end of the game and therefore he won
obviously
he should have converted the game in the
first place and then i got myself in a
position where i should have converted
and it was just uh he was a little bit
less [ __ ] than me so congratulations
yeah it was actually probably the best
games uh
because we've had swingy games but it's
usually because they're blundering like
10x the amount you guys were
uh and you guys played actually super
well i think at the end of game one
where you ended up drawing and i we
listened in on you a bit fenton
yeah i can hear you were kicking
yourself the entirety of game two
it was like move 30 and you're like i
should have closed game one man
i should have closed game uh it was it
was the only reason i was doing that
though it wasn't obviously
dave had opportunities to win as well
but uh is exactly what happy did when i
watched her
playing against pacman like david was a
lot lower to me on the clock and i
started playing quickly with david right
yeah and
taking my time and it was like half a
nanosecond later i seen
that he hung his rook and i could have
just taken him with my bishop and if i
had to just had a small bit of composure
i definitely would have won that game
and you know it is what it is
that's been a popular theme where the
tempo of the game
beats out your clock's time so if your
opponent plays fast you play fast
uh and i think game two you were going a
lot slower which was good
uh it ended up chewing out a little too
much of your clock so then you had to go
fast
just out of you know necessity to live
uh but still impressive games and i
think you're definitely a favorite now
for the consolation bracket
uh uh seeing the rest of the field i
think i think you
i don't want to say anything to take it
but i think you should i think you
absolutely should
and i think the thing you should take
away is don't count yourself out
because you were talking like you were
about to lose the whole game and then
you were leading both games you were
leading at one point
uh so i you know don't take yourself out
of the game
too soon uh because you you did find the
correct move
i think to take his rook right and have
a rook advantage in the game too
uh and and nearly and nearly win the
whole thing when you walked your queen
up to get the
rocked your pawn up i should say to get
the double queens that was uh
that was great that was a great find
lovey was saying it i had no idea was
talking about it and then you did it
like
frame one it was available it was you
know we were having a lot of
instant discussion i was like he has
this idea and we were like we might not
see it
pac-man what was your mentality you just
never count yourself out
well um yeah i mean basically just
i think in the games with hafu i played
terribly
but counted myself out whereas in this
game
i played terribly and just decided to
keep it going
specifically hoping that at some point
um clinton's
queen and king would be lined up i mean
exactly what i was waiting for happened
it only took like 40 tries you know i
mean it was like
yeah and eventually i saw you know that
that it was the opportunity to take the
queen
now i still do think that um
clinton could have won on time because i
agree
you know we were all surprised at that
yeah i think i mean it makes sense for i
think
where you were mentally and and how you
had you know you one at one point
thought you were done and then you were
winning and then you thought you were
done against very swingy
but i think residing there i had a pawn
against two full pieces and i just
didn't
true and i think if you're playing
against you know uh
any like international master it is over
but if you fight against me basically
pacman with 20 seconds left to find a a
you know a rook bishop king mate it's
not an easy task
exactly it's hard it was i recognized
that
you know if i had two rooks on the board
and that's a you know a pattern i've had
a ladder yeah exactly yeah exactly but i
was very much aware that um
i there was a good chance i wasn't going
to figure out mate and it was going to
come down to time
yeah so i would definitely fence in
hopefully in future games if there is
one takeaway it's
never count yourself out uh you know i
think you give your opponent a lot of
respect and credit which is good
uh but give yourself a little more
because you played really well today
and definitely you know on any given day
it was a coin flip you could have won it
and i think uh similar things will
happen in consolation
and i'm sure you'll tear your way
through many of the games there
uh thank you thank you again boys yeah
thank you david thank you uh fenton
for coming on great games yeah let's uh
let's just look ahead to what's tomorrow
that was 150 moves of chess
if not more that was a 160 moves of
chess
that's a lot of chess yeah wow
insanity uh both players have made
so much progress since the start of
pogchamps as well
um i know we were talking a lot about
the people who have put in time coming
into this event versus people who are
you know
on a little bit more relaxed or busy
schedule so yeah
what a finale there yeah i think it's
hyped to see people
so beat up about losing because it means
they're so passionate about a game
they just picked up you know what i mean
like you know
yeah i i'm not too beat up if i like
lose a game of war zone i never play
that game
right put your heart into something
within two weeks already you care about
the results
and you can just see the emotions on
their face but
let's move on and just tell everybody
what's coming up next on the schedule
so tomorrow we're going to see half
through julius take on
connor eats pants and the winner of the
two will make it on to the championship
bracket we do know hafner is a rating
favorite but
connor played very well considering he
had just learned chess before his game
with austin so that was impressive
and then we're going to see wagamama tv
versus austin show
i think austin can try to treat that as
a training game because
yeah it doesn't seem that he has chances
to make it into the championship bracket
anymore but it's still good practice
yeah uh and then and then while we're
finishing with uh with group c
to to wrap things up right so um
we've got ah we've got the uh
uh we got cutie so you have blade dog
dog and zextro
so i don't know um yeah both those
matches will be pretty key to see who
makes it out
uh amongst the three zextro dog dog and
tf played
so i think i think that day is very
impactful
on who will make it out and uh tomorrow
i think will be just interesting to see
how they play
chess specifically austin and connor
well it's been really fun doing
commentary with you two today
um i'm actually gonna be streaming after
this as well
so uh we're gonna have a pog chance
after party
at my channel and uh i'm only announcing
it because we're gonna raid my channel
anyway
sure sounds exciting and ludwig your
plans for the evening
i am going to go downstairs and watch my
roommate play breath of the wild and eat
a bagel
okay it's riveting levy any anything fun
on your end
i am picking out with mcdonald's later
that's been my plan since the morning
and uh i am going to do that uh we're
getting a big mac we get we get nuggets
we're getting the whole thing
and might even get an ice cream from
mcdonald's i'm mad
so uh hopefully chad is gonna
also have a good evening or morning it's
morning in some places which is
absolutely crazy
um and pogchamps continues tomorrow
uh with uh with group d we've gone
through it a million times but i already
forgot it
so uh till tomorrow see you all
perfect